quand le soleil se couche les régions
les plus proches de l'univers
apparaissent
nos plus proches voisins la lune et
vénus sont des phares stérile des
miroirs sans vie qui se contentent de
réfléchir la lumière
mais notre monde est un joyau brillant
débordant de vie d'une immense variété
est constamment changeant
quand les premiers astronautes vire la
terre de l'espace il admirait rhin
magnifique sa fille
notre planète bleue
deux jours si nous passons sous les
nuages la terre ressemble à n'importe
quel autre planète
aucun signe de vie de la présence des
hommes
la nuit le spectacle est différent ces
lumières sont la sicile
celle-là le delta du nil et d'israël
voici la californie éclairé et à droite
las vegas
la puissance de l'homme brille de mille
feux
en produisant de l'électricité nous
avons changé l'apparence de notre
planète nous avons apprivoisé les forces
de la nature qui nous a créés en
illuminant la nuit nous avons peut-être
assombri notre destin
les lumières de noville rendent
difficile l'observation des autres
planètes
nous devons les voir pour comprendre la
nôtre notre passé et notre futur
libéré de toute pollution lumineuse une
batterie d'instruments fouille le ciel à
la recherche d'un disque qui définissent
la place de la terre dans le système
solaire jupiter offre une version géante
dans notre climat
saturne peut paraître différentes mais
elle a été engendrée par les mêmes
forces cosmiques qui ont créé la terre
les forces qui ont laissé des calottes
glaciaires sur mars et des coulées de
lave sur vénus
notre planète se modifient sans cesse
sous l'influencé de deux grandes forces
la nature et l'action humaine
l'océan recouvre les deux tiers de la
terre et c'est pour ça que vue de
l'espace
la terre paraît si bleu
mais c'est sur la terre que l'affluence
de l'homme se fait surtout sentir
nous cultivons la terre et nous
extrayons le pétrole nous avons
construit des villes et des autoroutes
sillonnent les continents
nous avons transporté notre technologie
dans l'espace pour nous ramener ces
images
on
mais la nature continue à le défier
au japon les tremblements de terre
menace sans cesse volcan et typhons
secoue les philippines
où
sur le sous continent indien il y a des
moussons des cyclones et de terribles
inondations
le désert aride du sahara échappent au
contrôle de l'homme
jusqu'à christophe colomb l'atlantique
limiter la curiosité des hommes
dans le bassin amazonien la nature à
créer des plantes et des animaux mieux
adapté que nous à la chaleur étouffante
de la forêt
des explorateurs sont morts en tentant
de traverser les étendues glacées de
l'emporter
pourtant l'être humain refuse d'être
dominés nous avons colonisé tous les
coins de la terre des petites îles au
vaste continent
nous exploitons les ressources de la
terre et nous profitons des forces mêmes
qui nous ont donné notre planète
il y a quatre milliards et demi d'années
nous avons émergé d'un nuage cosmique un
disque tourbillonnant de gaz et de
poussière
le soleil s'est formée au centre et les
planètes du disque qui l'entouraient
sont nés des anneaux auto notre terre
primitive s'est formé à partir des
éléments lourds de la partie centrale du
système solaire
en se refroidissant la surface a durci
et une peau fragile s'est formé percée
de volcan crachant du feu et des gaz
empoisonné qui enveloppait la planète
mais au moins la paire avec une
atmosphère tandis que les gaz se
condenser la pluie commence à tomber
l'eau remplit les dépressions les
premiers océan entourèrent des
continents primitif la planète terre se
colorera de bleu
pourtant les volcans continuer à cracher
du feu
aussi étrange que cela paraisse c'est
peut être eux qui ont permis à la vie
d'apparaître
des molécules organiques complexes ce
sont probablement formé dans
l'atmosphère à partir de ces gaz nocifs
pendant les millions d'années que durera
la pluie ces molécules tombé du ciel
dans les océans où se déroulèrent toute
une série de réactions chimiques
quelque part dans les profondeurs des
vagues les premières cellules vivantes
se formèrent
des mères elles se répandirent sur la
terre
et tandis que l'atmosphère
s'éclaircissent et le soleil brille à à
travers les nuages les cellules se
servir du soleil comme source d'énergie
et des plantes poussèrent elle
colonisèrent le monde et produisirent un
nouveau gars
dans le processus connu sous le nom de
photosynthèse la lumière du soleil et le
gaz carbonique furent absorbée par les
plantes qui produisirent de l'oxygène
peu un peu l'air de vin respirable pour
des animaux qui pourrait évoluer
oh
voici à quoi ressemblerait la terre si
tous les océans se vident et de l'euro
un relief aride de plein art est élargie
canyon
incroyablement semblable à mars si la
planète rouge avec des océans
elle serait bleus
même venus dépouillé de ses nuages
ressemble à la terre
elles sont jumelles par la taille
un survol de vénus révèle un terrain
familier
un sommet volcaniques
un paysage qui pourrait ressembler à
l'aube de la terre s'il n'y avait une
atmosphère infernal de gaz carbonique un
effet de serre incontrôlée qui rend
toute vie impossible
mars et la terre partagent le même
héritage géologiques les mêmes
conditions météorologiques érosion et
faye qui a donné naissance au grand
canyon en amérique et à la vallée du
rift en afrique
il ne manque à mars qu'une atmosphère
respirable des maires et des lacs est la
vie
sur notre planète bleue le pacifique au
nord de la nouvelle guinée la crevasse
dans l'océan et la fosse des mariannes
profonde peu 11 km la copie d'un canyon
sur mars
les lignes de faille qui ont fait
trembler la californie la fosse
méditerranéenne qui sépare l'europe de
l'afrique
la faille de la mer rouge qui sépare
l'afrique de l'arabie des volcans dans
l'atlantique
tout cela pourrait se trouver sur mars
mais au contraire de mars et de vénus la
terre change constamment dans la dorsale
au milieu de l'atlantique le fond de la
mer se froisse et éloigne le continent
américain de l'afrique et de l'europe à
la vitesse de 2 cm et demi par an
à partir d'un super continent unique il
y à 250 millions d'années les masses
terrestres se sont séparés elles se sont
déplacées sur des plaques tectoniques
flottant sur dieu magma fondu
les points rouges représentent des
volcans il marque les failles ou les
plaques se rejoignent les plaques
s'encastre les unes sur les autres
ou comme ici se sépare les effets de
leur séparation sont similaires aux
phénomènes visibles dans ce lac de lave
comme des plaques se rejoignant les
conséquences peuvent être
catastrophiques
des photos satellites d'une colonne lors
de l'éruption du mont pinatubo aux
philippines transporter jusqu'à la
stratosphère les cendres volcaniques ont
encerclé la terre et la température de
notre planète a chuté d'un demi degré
les causes des modifications de pima
durable sont moins évidentes
il y a vingt mille ans la terre
connaissait une période glaciaire dont
l'antarctique est aujourd'hui le seul
vestige
dans l'hémisphère nord les glaciers
s'étendait jusqu'à new york l'ong une
période glaciaire peut survenir à
nouveau sans que l'on sache ni quand ni
pourquoi nous ne pouvons qu'être
reconnaissant que l'avancé annuel des
glaces fasse partie d'un cycle
saisonnier
non
des mesures prises de 1979 à 1990
indique que les produits chimiques
industriels ont pu altérer l'atmosphère
un trou s'est formée dans la couche
d'ozone la couverture qui nous protège
des rayons ultraviolets nocifs du soleil
les dégâts irréversibles
on peut être été commis
en asie centrale voici une autre
conséquence possible de l'intervention
humaine la merde aral les cultures et
l'industrie ont perçu un lourd tribut de
ses affluents
en trente ans la mère a diminué de 40%
et les villages de pêcheurs qui
l'abordaient sont maintenant dans les
terres
oui
nous pouvons abîmé notre planète
dans le golfe persique nous avons craint
que les puits de pétrole enflammé lors
de la guerre du golfe en 1991 ne
contribuent au réchauffement global
le koweit a connu un hiver nucléaire et
bahreïn l'hiver le plus froid depuis 35
ans mais autant que nous pouvons en
juger la nature nous a pardonné
au brésil toutes les dix minutes un
hectare de forêt tropicale et abattus et
brûlés quelles sont les conséquences sur
notre provisions d'oxygène et est ce que
ces feux augmente l'effet de serre
le climat de la terre est conditionné
par l'air chaud qui s'élève à l'équateur
et remonte vers les pôles aux latitudes
intermédiaire cet air chaud rencontre de
l'air froid qui descend dépôt ces
mouvements détermine les conditions
météorologiques
mais notre climat et surtout contrôlé
par le soleil sa chaleur est conservé
dans notre atmosphère par le dioxyde de
carbone l'équilibré fragile trop de gaz
carbonique frais de la terre une serre
comme vénus le soleil tire son énergie
du réacteur nucléaire en son centre
des éruptions de feu plusieurs fois plus
grande que la terre s'échappe dans
l'espace
des explosions égal à plusieurs millions
de bombes nucléaires envoie des ondes de
choc à travers la surface du soleil
150 millions de kilomètres plus loin
cette furie se transforme en lumière et
chaleur bienveillant
sans le soleil la photosynthèse serait
impossible
il n'y aurait donc pas d'oxygène pour
respirer
il n'y aurait pas de nourriture pour les
milliards des espèces qui peuplent la
terre
pas de carbone pour construire les
troncs d'arbres qui nous donne charbon
et pétrole
notre planète bleue
mais un an pour tourner autour du soleil
et c'est l'inclinaison de l'axé de la
terre qui détermine les changements des
saisons quand un hémisphère et tourné
vers le soleil
c'est l'été dans l'autre où les rayons
du soleil sont plus au blick
c'est l'hiver jour après jour saison
après saison
l'angle de la lumière du soleil change
et la couleur de notre planète se
modifie ici en afrique
des images prises par satellite reflète
le cycle des saisons la croissance et la
décomposition de la végétation sur une
échelle globale la terre à deux ceinture
de végétation une dans chaque hémisphère
comme les partenaires d'une danse
éternelles elles avancent et reculent en
rythme avec la fonte et le gel les
calottes glaciaires la terre est plus
verte dans l'hémisphère en été est
penché vers le soleil
la navette spatiale et les satellites
voit ce qui se passe sous la croûte
terrestre
grâce à des radars spéciaux il traverse
non seulement les nuages mais les océans
et les couches supérieures de terre
il voit à travers les déserts pour
suivre le cours de rivières asséchées et
à travers la jungle d'amérique centrale
pour suivre d'anciennes route maya
ici en fausses couleurs le jaune révèle
une vieille neige compactée au milieu
d'une neige fraîchement tombée en
californie les taches violettes sont des
nouvelles coulées de lave du volcan
mauna loa sur l'île d'hawaï
en amérique du sud la lumière bleue
indique les forêts a battu dans le
bassin amazonien
les glaciers des alpes autrichiennes
aide à identifier les conditions dans
les montagnes au moins accessible
et pour qui sait voir une ville perdue
sous les sables d'arabie
grâce aux radars de l'espace nous
pouvons réaliser des cartes
tridimensionnel cette île se trouve dans
les galapagos
les ordinateurs peuvent nous faire
voyager partout dans la base de données
et nous permettre de mieux explorer
notre monde
et
à nouveau une carte en trois dimensions
de la vallée de la mort en californie
vue d'un satellite la péninsule de
monterey en californie
mais souvent les différents ils nous en
prennent sous les vagues et dans les
océans
au dessus des radeaux de plancton vert
est en dessous le fond de l'océan
pacifique
l'ordinateur peut ajouter les courants
ces grands mouvements des eaux qui
transporte le froid le chaud autour du
globe
les vents de l'océan
des images prises par des satellites et
affinés par des ordinateurs des cartes
pour les marins des plans de culture
pour les fermiers
après le soleil c'est la lune qui exerce
la plus grande influence sur la terre
pendant quatre milliards et demi
d'années la résistance lié à la gravité
lunaire a peu à peu ralenti notre
rotation sans la lune la terre
tournerait si vite qu'une journée ne
durerait que deezer
comparé à la terre la lune est minuscule
elle tiendrait sur la surface de
l'amérique du nord
le diamètre de la terre est presque
quatre fois plus grand que celui de la
lune la terre mesure presque treize
mille kilomètres de diamètre 30 terres
mises bout-à-bout couvrirait la distance
de la terre à la lune la lune est si
proche qu'elle exerce une forte
attraction gravitationnelle ce qui nous
donne nos marais
la lune attire les maires deux fois par
jour la combinaison de son mouvement
orbital et de la rotation de la terre en
traîne un flux et un reflux qui peuvent
transformer une île en une péninsule
la lune n'est pas assez grande pour
retenir une atmosphère le petit pas de
neil amstrong tirer son énergie
d'oxygène apportée de la terre si nous
voulons pouvoir nous installer sur la
lune
il faudra créer notre environnement il
faudra y faire pousser des plantes pour
se nourrir
recréer les cycles de la terre dans une
capsule
dans les siècles à venir ne deviendront
peut-être une rast fermiers de l'espace
nous irons en vacances dans des stations
touristiques en orbite autour de notre
monde
nous pourrions remodelé mars à l'image
de la terre mais où que nous allions
nous devrons transporté avec nous les
systèmes qui permettent la vie développé
uniquement par notre planète bleue